he hates birdman in a very irrational  way really why you gotta tell us I just  Pat I passionately hate that movie it's  good I think it was a catastrophe that  you blame the worst in one hostage  yeah exactly I do badly I'm baffled you  know what movie I haven't seen you what  a piece of [ __ ] that movie was and how  many awards have one I thought it was  good don't listen any plays baseball on  PlayStation 4 wait that the Birdman  being bad movie a dog it's an amazing  game yeah baseball you just didn't like  that he PlayStation 4 is capable of and  you played baseball on it I don't know  anything about playstation i didn't have  video games going game play stone it's  very sensitive controls the pitching is  right on gotta warm them guys up you get  really into it the stats the numbers  manat gonna get